according to the New York Post the
leftist billionaire through another
group he donated to is dumping hundreds
of thousands of dollars to groups of
tick talkers called gen Z for change now
these folks uh you know aren't as any
Tick Tock Stars though they are the same
ones that the Biden Administration
pretty smartly relied on heavily to push
his agenda its founder even met with the
president just a few months ago at the
White House so joining me now is Morgan
McMichael Turning Point USA contributor
Morgan I know you're all over this story
but this is something that conservatives
on social media like yourself
um you know they haven't been really on
top of yet it's so obvious how it works
how much is this hurting the movement
it's very obvious for what's going on I
mean they should be called gen Z for the
establishment instead of gen Z for
change I mean they're being paid to
shill for our leftist Elites that are
controlling the world's economy and
they're doing it directly in front of
our faces I mean this is why the work of
Turning Point USA is super important
because we're safeguarding free speech
and conservative ideas I mean me and
myself I've been banned on Tick Tock six
times so we know that the elites are in
the pockets of big Tech and so now the
same Elites are in the pockets of the
same influencers that are promoting the
propaganda and doing the propaganda
bidding for the world's Elites so really
we're gone hold on hold on hold on
Morgan take a breath hold on I have a
question
like you're young you're really
energetic you're enthusiastic you've
been banned a bunch of times so what you
can get unbanned or you can go on and
start other accounts but there should be
a hundred people like you who are
preaching the gospel of free market
capitalism strong borders fair trade all
the things we care about and a clean
clean environment a same same Society
all you guys can do that and it could be
really powerful so are we are you I mean
we are we are promoting these
conservative ideas all over the Internet
and on college campuses and high school
campuses around the country but the
problem is is Big Tech doesn't have
those same standards for conservative
voices like they do for these liberal
voices if you notice gen Z for change
has over a million followers on Tick
Tock and my accounts couldn't even
surpass a hundred two hundred thousand
before getting permanently banned on the
platforms multiple times so we're
dealing with censorship issues which is
why we need to keep the pressure on
harder and it's really no surprise that
the establishment the elites are funding
it behind it well I think we also have
to remember this is why people like Mike
Pence Mike Pence Mike Pompeo and others
have been saying for years now that tick
tock's got to go I mean the idea that
we're allowing China to have any uh you
know foothold into U.S thought
especially about issues like climate
change when they're never going to do
anything about climate changes that that
in and of itself is is crazy but to your
point about this gen Z for change group
the founder is a Harvard freshman
explaining what winning looks like for I
guess it would be your entire generation
Morgan watch this
we are unequivocally supportive of
Medicare for all the green New Deal
Palestinian liberation
a plethora of progressive policies that
a vast majority of gen z uh supports
winning for Gen Z means electing
progressives who are willing to disrupt
the status quo
oh my gosh the fact that any one of your
age would think that's smart God bless
him but he's not exactly the font of
young strength or
it's not very attractive but why is it
why does that work no I guess why does
that work
I mean they're promoting this kind of
stuff on college campuses across the
country recently I was at a college
campus that had a Marxist communist club
which is insane that these type of clubs
are actually allowed on college campuses
and now even infiltrating social media I
mean I really think the House GOP needs
to investigate where this dark money is
coming from funneling to these
influencers to promote this ideas on the
internet because if they're not branding
their content properly not only are they
breaking FTC guidelines but this could
really be seen as election interference
and it's going on on every single
platform right now well I think
conservatives have to get really smart
really funny and really bold and how
they have their own message going out
we're gone thank you so much great to
see you hi everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now